[Music]
we've seen a deterioration
of
this view of business or view of success
the
the success has become there's an enemy
yeah there's a a war on
success a w particularly a war on
business all business is evil all rich
people are evil all successful people
are evil
and
it's gotten just and social media has
hyped it up even more
and less mature voices
uh more ridiculous voices have added to
the this this war on success
and you know with this idea that
business executives are overpaid they're
greedy and and
all all of this that the rich don't pay
their fair share and that runs contrary
to uh to a jewish belief system
yes very much so
and it's precisely that jewish belief
system that has
created
what you alluded to earlier is
disproportionate jewish success with
money but in as much as you also said
earlier brothers from a different mother
and the connection
it also lies at the heart
of what max weber wrote about a hundred
years ago which is the protestant ethic
and the spirit of capitalism
it's not an accident
that that is what has created wealth in
what we think of as the west
but in in practical terms what's what
what has happened in in the country at
the moment certainly in this country and
also in many other countries
is that there is been a
a collapse of an understanding of the
spiritual now i just want to make
absolutely clear that when i say
spiritual i'm speaking from the point of
view of my background as a physicist not
as my background as a rabbi
so when i say spiritual i don't mean
holy or godly or anything at all i mean
there's good spiritual there's spiritual
just means things that you cannot
measure in a lab
and so a violin or a saxophone are
physical i can measure their weight and
how long they are a tune
is indistinguishable from a noise
according to any
lab laboratory instrument
what transforms right what converts
vibrating air molecules into a tune that
can make you happy and make you dance or
make men march off to war or bring a
lump to your throat all of that happens
between our ears in our brains in our
hearts and our souls and so music is
spiritual a musical instrument is
physical and so the the key question
becomes what is money you know is it
disks of metal or strips of colored
paper or how about it's the orientation
of iron oxide molecules on the magnetic
stripe behind your credit card or zeros
and ones on your financial institutions
computer
what is money and it's a really
important question because if it's
physical then it corresponds to the laws
of physics and one of the immutable laws
of physics is that something can only be
in one place at a time
and so
this book
right here is now here with me
and if i turn away a moment and i turn
back and it's now with you you took my
book
there's no other solution but if i
if i
teach you a tune and you go away here
with my tune you've taken nothing away
from me
spiritual things can be in more than one
place at a time physical things can't
and that's where it gets critical
because if money is physical then if you
have a few dollars you must have taken
it from other people you see socialists
secularists atheists don't comprehend
the idea of making money they understand
taking of money
it's a very very different thing and the
whole idea that money can come into
existence as spontaneously as a tune can
is alien and so you know i can i could
sit in a room all by myself and compose
a tune and then send it off by uh as an
mp3 file to my publisher and my
publisher markets it and and starts
collecting royalties and he can then
order a caterer to send a meal to my
room and i've produced something
concrete and tangible and physical in
the form of a meal in my room
come about purely because of a spiritual
act of creativity and so what's happened
is over the last 20 years that that you
and i have been talking there has been a
marked deterioration in people's
comprehension of of spiritual hugely
important for everybody trying to make a
living everybody trying to build a
business because a good number of the
decisions that we make in life
particularly financial decisions are
made for spiritual not physical or
utilitarian reasons
and so when a certain lady i know very
well whose name i will not reveal
drives across town because her little
app shows her gasoline cost less
in another place the fact that i
explained to it's not worth your time
it's not worth the the the wear and tear
on the car just buy the gasoline
wherever it is she says no i can't do
that well she grew up in new york she
can't do anything else that's a
spiritual thing when a person pays more
money for a pair of jeans that's got a
funny label on it
why
it doesn't it does it's it's all these
are all spiritual reasons well i love
their phrases uh the difference in
making money
making money means creating
you created out of nothing out of wealth
that's where my creativity
rather than taking you know everyone
says the fixed pie right it's not a
fixed pie all right talk about one of my
favorite riffs is candles and cakes
yeah well it's the same as musical
instruments and music and tunes and that
is that
money is brought into existence when one
of god's children does something for
another
now we can use the right terminology we
can call it marketing we can call it
sales
service we can call it service and
there's a reason why we have a worship
service and we also say customer service
those two are related and
and and we can look at our financial
statements as a as a detached and
vitally important set of data as to how
our business is doing but what is
important not to lose track of is that
at its root it's service to another
human being if that doesn't happen you
don't have a business in the same way
that we'd say if you do not have profit
you don't actually have a business
you're a hobby you have a hobby that's
right it's a good that's a great way of
putting it yeah uh if your profit if
your revenue doesn't in
isn't more than your expenses you do not
have a business the socialist fallacy is
like you said earlier if i take the book
you don't have the book and so if
they look at the economy as cake yes
that if i uh if i get a big if you get a
bigger slice that means there's not as
much left for me
and you have taken yes rather than made
correct and that distinction in the in
the first segment was vital uh and you
say that is not how the economy works
well it's i put it this way there are
two ways of getting money into your
pocket
one way is by serving another human
being it might be a customer client a
boss anybody
another way is using a 357 magnum
revolver
now somebody who decides to get money
that way comes home from work at the end
of the day and uh his wife says honey
how was your day says not bad you know
did okay she said how much did you take
and he says you know i i held up three
people i took a total of about 150
dollars in some odd change
you know that's one way of getting money
and the other way is actually serving
other human beings who then give money
to you voluntarily and
the essence of business is also the
essence of being a good human being
which is finding ways
to please other human beings it's
beautiful it's a wonderful thing to do
and it's limitless absolutely limitless
that's why the idea of the cake example
is so fallacious there's only so much
cake you took too much you know you got
all kinds of things must be you took it
from me this generates envy and
unpleasantness and recrimination and
basically breaks a part of society which
is what we see happening it's not an
accident that no atheistic regime has
ever succeeded in building an effective
economy it can't happen that's why we
have the words in god we trust not on
the walls of churches but on the
currency
so instead of cake it's candles
candles you can light your candle from
my burning candle you've taken nothing
from me you've just brought more light
into the world it's the christmas eve
service yes when i light your candle you
light another candle you light another
candle you light another candle in the
whole place beautiful now and it started
dark
but no one stole no one was diminished
that's right by passing their light
along
and by passing the service along you're
not diminished if you view money
correctly because it is um that's why
they call it a currency is because it is
a current yes it is not a fixed item
great point it's not a fixed item right
so uh changing gears just second before
i before we run out of this segment
because i want to be sure to get as much
of your wisdom as i can get thank you um
one of the things you've said recently
that has jived again with something that
i believe is you said that a completely
different subject that leaders who are
not
willing to engage in confrontation are
not leaders yes
talk about that yeah of course people
don't like hearing that because today
the whole you know
toxic masculinity and after all it's
masculine to be willing to confront etc
etc and so there's this huge attack on
this but but look um i think the first
thing to recognize is you know who is
the biggest villain in your life who has
caused you more aggravation through all
your life than anybody else who is it
who has obstructed you at every turn
who's made life difficult for you
i got a clue his name is on your driving
license
and it's in your mirror yes she's in
your mirror exactly so uh so
the most important thing is to be able
to confront yourself
and you know pop psychology keeps
telling us we worry about your
self-esteem i'm terrific everything i'm
doing no you screwed up
you know stop doing that it isn't any
good so being able to confront yourself
obviously is is a very crucial step in
building a business and developing
financial independence and financial
peace
uh you know everybody knows they
shouldn't spend more than they make so
now that that knowledge is there why are
you still around we why do we need you
you've told us what to do
and the answer is information is not
enough there has to be inspiration as
well and that is the spiritual dimension
um absolutely pat lynchian talks about
in his book the advantage that a company
that creates a corporate culture
of healthy conflict yes is the has a
brand advantage over any other company
that does any other thing you you beat
smart people great point people smarter
than you every time if you can have a
mentally healthy organization that does
healthy conflict and leaders that will
not create healthy conflict for the good
of progress yes are not real leaders and
uh they're just acquiescing and um you
get a neville chamberlain event when you
have just acquiescing that's right and
uh and that will birth the church hill
yeah that's what it'll do so uh wow it
happens on the world stage and happens
in our little businesses and in our
little lives it's so relevant